bonjour à toutes et à tous aujourd'hui
je répondre à une question que des
millions d'enfants ont posé à leurs
parents et à laquelle ces derniers n'ont
pas toujours su répondre
allez au boulot à l'est c'est rigolo ça
[Musique]
tout commence dans un pré où poussent de
la bonne herbe bien grasse bon celle ci
manque un peu de fraîcheur
et si on allait à la campagne dans un
vrai prix une vraie ferme au milieu de
vraies vaches à lait c'est parti
[Musique]
elles sont belles ce sont des vaches
laitières
il ya des prim'holstein dg riez les
petites marron et il y a même normande
au milieu du troupeau
ce sont elles qui produisent le lait
qu'on consomme le matin est aussi celui
avec lequel on fait du beurre de la
crème fraîche des yaourts ou du
camembert
elle adore ses pâturages normal on est
en normandie
tiens d'ailleurs ça me rappelle une
chanson les vaches rousses dans les
champs sur lesquels tombe la pluie et le
bon cidre doux mais des normandie la
ferme
oui je sais on y va à la ferme mais
avant on en profite
en france il existe dix sept races de
vaches laitières qui ont des noeuds
adorable il y à la bleue du nord la
jersey on l'a dit la montbéliard
l'abondance la tarentaise l'appli rouge
la rouge flamande la simmental
j'en passe et puis bien sûr la
prim'holstein qui représente le plus
gros troupeau ses vaches produisent plus
ou moins de lait à l'est plus ou moins
riches plus ou moins gras tout dépend ce
que l'on fait avec on estime qu'une
vaches broutent en moyenne 60 kg d'herbe
fraîche par jour et pas n'importe quelle
herbe
elle adore le trèfle de la luzerne mais
ici ce qu'elle préfère c'est leur ira
l'hiver quand elles sont allées table on
leur donne du foin ou de l'ensilage que
l'éleveur peut compléter harry des
céréales du soja elles boivent aussi
beaucoup de 70 à 100 litres d'eau par
jour
alors évidemment pour digérer tout ça il
faut du temps on dit qu elle rumine
elle y consacre 14 heures par jour un
vrai boulot et ça ne risque pas de faire
tourner le lait pour le moment c'est le
système digestif de la vache qui tourne
à fond je vais vous montrer
les vaches sont des ruminent leur
système digestif ne fonctionne pas comme
le nôtre on dit souvent qu elles ont
quatre estomacs en fait elles n'ont
aucun mais le travail est pré mâchée si
je puis dire par trois poches qui se
trouve en amont pour comprendre
on va suivre le trajet d'une touffe
d'herbe dans le système digestif de la
vache c'est un schéma bien sur l'herbe
brouter et grossièrement mâché et imbibé
d'une grande quantité de salive
elle est avalée et descend le long de
l'oesophage elle stationne dans un
premier réservoir le réseau ça ne traîne
pas et qu'il y a de la place à l'étagé
inférieur l'herbe des sans direction
le rumen c'est ici que les choses
sérieuses commencent
cette poche fait environ 150 litres la
taille d'une baignoire en pro l'herbe
est prise d'assaut par une armée de
bactéries et de champignons qui commence
à dégrader les fibres végétales
c'est un travail difficile l'herbe
remonte régulièrement dans la bouche
pour à nouveau être mâchée et un livret
de salive
j'ai compté la vache mâchouille une
cinquantaine de fois avant d'avaler à
nouveau la nourriture et c'est cette
activité que l'on appelle la rumination
cas d'ailleurs rumination rumen c'est la
même racine
elle note aussi les racines mais non je
parle de la racine du mot son étymologie
après plusieurs allers-retours le
mélange se dirige vers le feuillet
désormais il ne remontera plus à la
surface puis il passe dans la caillette
le véritable estomac de la vache ou la
cellulose est dégradée cette bouillie
est ensuite évacué dans l'intestin ou
son récupérer tous les éléments
nutritifs
je vois toujours pas de vache à lait -
julie ça tourne mal cette histoire et
lavage à bien utiliser ces éléments pour
fabriquer du lait mais pour en produire
il faut un vous c'est la naissance du
veau qui va déclencher ce qu'on appelle
la lactation allaient pourtant dans la
ferme
dans les douze heures qui suivent sa
naissance leveaux va boire le lait de sa
mère
celui ci est né ce matin c'est un lait
très riche qu'on appelle le colostrum ce
lait produit par lavage durant les
premiers jours n'est pas consommée par
les humains mais il est indispensable
aux veaux pour qu'ils fabriquent ses
défenses naturelles et il en a bien
besoin
ensuite une petite semaine après sa
naissance il est séparé de sa mère
nourri au biberon avec son lait puis peu
à peu apprendre à manger des aliments
solides comme de l'herbe et du fourrage
au milieu des autres vos de la ferme
avec qui j'ai grandi et pendant ce temps
la vache produit du lait
comment fait-elle lavage possède un pee
et 4 mamelles et non l'averse qui se
prononce chacune vers un trait lyon 1 2
3 4
d'où l'expression se mélangent les
trayons eux non les crayons je crois
c'est une hormone qui déclenche la
fabrication du lait les cellules de
chaque mam elle utilise les nutriments
récupérer dans l'herbe est véhiculée par
le sang pour fabriquer le précieux
liquide qu'elle se gorge de l'est comme
une multitude de petites éponges
il est alors temps de traire la vache
mais les mamelles ne libère pas le lait
sur demande c'est beaucoup plus délicat
c'est encore une hormone qui déclenche
le mécanisme quand on espère la nature
c'est le museau du veau qui en jouant
avec le trayon déclenche la production
de cette hormone l'ocytocine celle de
l'attachement quand elle arrive au
niveau des cellules elles déclenchent à
son tour l'écoulement du lait vers les
trayons à les tables c'est l'éleveur qui
en manipulant délicatement le trayon
déclenché ce processus oh je crois que
c'est l'heure de la traite
on va les voir comment savent pas
en vrai
[Musique]
bonjour antoine georges amis ras c'est
vrai quoi bon ils ont pas l'air stressé
on reçoit la cool moi c'est la traite
selon l'habitude matin et soir deux fois
par jour à la trêve
oui tous les matins tous les soirs tous
les jours de l'année voilà alors comment
on procède ba écoute tu vas voir ça je
vais te montrer
il ya des matches qui vont arriver on va
les nettoyer ça laisse un fini 13e
l'effort d'accord alors une fois qu'on a
rentré les vaches je vais passer du
savon sur les trayons alors là
l'objectif c'est de débarrasser les
trayons débat quéré parce que lorsque le
l'essor du pays il est parfaitement
stérile et donc là on va nettoyer le
trayon avec un papier c'est un papier
pour chaque vache donc en fait on
s'abonne et ensuite un petit coup de
gueule en quelque sorte si la toile est
exactement la planète presque à sec et
on va on va poser la griffe
alors c'est un drôle de nom mais ça ne
griffe pas du tout on l'appelle comme ça
juste à cause de sa forme finalement
exactement c'est jusque là avec les
manchons qui vont à la fois inspiré et
malaxer le crayon pour permettre
l'expression du recul et qui va passer
dans ce trio là alors la traite d'une
vache dure entre 4 et 8 minutes et
chaque vache va fournir entre 10 et 20
litres de lait par traiter quand c'est
terminé et bien antoine dépose sur
chaque crayon un produit désinfectant et
hydratant car il faut en prendre treize
points de ses petit rayon effectivement
c'est un produit cosmétique pour
hydrater et à s'offrir le crayon qui est
sollicitée pendant la traite et ensuite
une solution désinfectante dedans qui
permet de protéger la mamelle des
microbes jusqu'à la traite jusqu'à la
traite après
le lait est stockée dans un réservoir en
inox qu'on appelle un tank à lait il
passe en quelques minutes de 40° à 4°
ceux ci pourraient être conservés dans
de bonnes conditions
jusqu'à la collecte qui a lieu tous les
deux jours le jour de la collecte
on prélève un échantillon on l'analyse
puis le lait est transportée jusqu'à la
laiterie où il va subir d'autres
contrôles avant d'être conditionnés pour
être vendus ou transformées gilou très
bien quand même
antoine et c'est le moment de la
dégustation donc là on a deux les
jersiaise et prim'holstein qui est qui
alors jetez midi les deux de
prim'holstein danse vers la haye du lait
jazz y est dense vers la voûte le
premier et tu vas voir c'est ce qui
ressemble plus sur les classiques ça me
rappelle le lait que je buvais dans les
tables de mon grand-père quand j'étais
petit ça fait des sous c'est très bon
donc ça c'est l'année de prim'holstein
et maintenant le lait de gervaise il ya
déjà une différence à la couleur oui
franchement elle mange de l'herbe qui
est riche en carotène les jarretières
fonds 1 les plus riches
donc en fait les éléments sont
concentrées dedans et donc c'est pour ça
qu'ils semblent plus jaune et un goût
aussi il est plus fort
et oui parce qu'en fait les jersiais
seront moins gelé mais elle est beaucoup
plus riche si tu veux le lait de
prim'holstein il est à peu près 4 % de
matière grasse et celui de janvier à 6 %
de matière grasse et aussi en matière
protéique des plus riches en matières
protéiques ont fait plus de beurre et
plus de fromage avec un litre de lait
jazz y est ce qu'avec un litre de lait
prim'holstein et de la crème fraîche
aussi éclairé à crème fraîche aussi et
ça m'étonne pas parce que ça passe crème
comme on dit elle voit avec ces barbiche
un petit peu comme les chats avec leur
vie bri
voilà regarde elle en train de manger
mon blouson tu aimes la plume d'oie toi
c'est bizarre très bizarre comme vache
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]